yeah oh my god what incriminating things
are out in the open right now I wash my
dishes just for you guys and I left them
out so you can just fully know that I
wash them domestic at school and not
words that it doesn't work as well when
you don't were self hi guys my name is
very salty if you know now you know your
life is different now welcome to my
first cooking video in my new kitchen
how exciting
no it's space to make some sound quality
of this video it's still January of the
new year which means a lot of people are
probably waning on their health
resolutions and resolutions are just
like tiny lies that we tell ourselves
voluntary obstacles that we set up for
ourselves with good intention so for all
of you that are on a health kick this
year but really I'm kicking yourselves
because she sucks eat healthy I got you
covered
I find that the best way to eat healthy
is by lying to yourself so today I want
to teach you how to make up lyonia it's
basically a lasagna but it's not so
first thing we're gonna do to make a
wise Anya is make a lasagna Remick half
a lasagna very thin layer of lasagna I
found the recipe on Pinterest that's
what I'm following and I cut it in half
I need to preheat my oven to 350 degrees
slam nice okay currently preheating now
at the chop half an onion watch this I
won't even cry because my emotions are
made of solid steel the recipe calls for
one onion I'm doing a half of an onion
which is perfect as that's the only
amount of onion I had in my refrigerator
haha chopping onions is easy when you
feel nothing onion has been chopped
now how much garlic do we chop 3 cloves
of garlic which means one and a half
cloves of garlic for us that's how I get
the garlic peel off except this one
already had the peel off so I just
smashed it for no reason I just smashed
eternal rebirth that every frat boy ever
how's your 2017 oh 2016 like a horny
college freshman getting action and 2017
came in and was like a recently divorced
deeply repressed 40-something year old
wife getting real fun Oh cute that's my
analogy how do you think 2017 is versus
2016 so in a large pan we're going to
add oil onions and garlic and we're the
until this is translucent like all great
YouTube personalities completely
translucent you can see right through us
there onions and garlic in that pan you
got some hot not that one no hot no no
honest and garlic and all right our
onions and garlic are kind of
translucent aka I'm impatient so now
we're going to add our meat sis I'm
using ground turkey you can use it over
the 51 you can also use no meat okay sir
- goes there perfect cooking no that's
paper oh my god I'm really good at
cooking I'm doing okay Wow Wow
we're going to cook our ground turkey
until it's cooked which is what cooks
met the first time but I just look like
that and we're going to drain all the
fat out of it and return it to the same
pan that it's cooking in right now now
we drain the fat off the nurse because
we have tomato sauce tomato paste water
oregano basil salt and pepper I got some
tomato sauce but then I opened my tomato
panel our Sun ripened California tomato
paste and this is what was inside
gusting I don't think that's right that
seems incredibly wrong used by September
2018 I don't think that that's what
tomato paste is supposed to look like
but I'm not going to use many tomato
paste
hey this is all a lie anyway so we're
going to add one can 15 ounces of tomato
sauce I have a teaspoon of oregano and
half a teaspoon of basil whatever you
want for some pepper we're gonna bring
that [ __ ] to a boil and then we have to
let it cook on low for 15 to 20 minutes
and then time us out correctly they
lobbied and they all folks are gonna
tell you never can tell remember tomato
paste oh so gross that's boiling so now
we're going to reduce the heat and cover
this up and cook for 15 to 20 minutes
BRB okay that meat mixtures and cooking
for a decent amount of time I mean I
think it's fine my expectations are low
my rewards are mediocre so now we're
going to construct our lasagna
I bought these fresh sheets
now if you have other lasagna sheets
you're supposed to cook them but I don't
think you're supposed to cook these
because they'll cook in the oven with
lasagna so I got these like a manila
folder that you can eat I cut them into
strips because that lasagna right I
don't know I've never actually made a
lasagna
the first thing I'm gonna do is put some
soft in this pan so that things don't
stick to the pan
it's the noodles not stick your nud
looking at you need now according to
this recipe we put our noodles down
alright did that now let's put our meat
mixture down Oh get in there meat look
at you then it says it was the egg
cottage cheese on top I don't know I
don't know I don't know I don't know I
don't know a lot of recipes use ricotta
cheese but this one uses cottage cheese
because I think it just hates itself wow
that looks like it's not gonna be good
now we sprinkle some parmesan
Wow then we sprinkle some mozzarella
cheese that I have grated into this bowl
you all look so fun and cool but you're
gonna hurt me so hard
you're like bunch of sorority girls and
I'm just a nerd willing to help you with
your finals we're going to add one more
layer of noodle and then we're going to
put a little bit just a really thin
layer of our mixes what's four more
parmesan you cottage cheese and some
more mozzarella basically like half of
our dishes filled with lasagna we're
gonna put this in the oven for that's a
minute
well that cooks I'm going to clean up
ah-ha we're back and I think the
lasagnas done I just don't care anymore
I'm impatient that looks like old Anya
right don't tell me otherwise just
pander to me please this is the part
that I didn't actually sink through this
is the part that was awesome in theory
and now that I have to do it in practice
I didn't think through it alright so
here's where our lives on your
conscience so basically what you need is
another was Anya's dish and if you have
one that's opaque this metal that's not
clear glass that's even better because
we're trying to make this alive Anya
that means that we're trying to make it
healthy that means that we're trying to
trick you into thinking that you're
eating something that's bad for you but
surprise it's good for you so so I
bought a Caesar salad kit and I've made
a Caesar salad
I'm going to put the Caesar salad down
as the first layer in this pan lambs and
clams
in person and then what I'm going to do
is try and transport this lasagna to the
top of this salad only uh-oh oh I ruined
it I read everything's fine
oh yeah oh my god oh my god basically
just want to cover all of the salad we
might have done it oh my god oh my god
we might only I may have been oh and
there you have it you have a live Vanya
it looks like a lasagna on top but when
you cut into it there's a salad
underneath you go cry so hard ready
watch this we do homemade lasagna hmm I
shouldn't have any but man that looks
really good no one's looking I'm gonna
have some they may just cut into it
really quickly here we go Aled
underneath why I've been lied to in the
best way possible
Oh hot lettuce is whatever almost have
put in their body right
you know what that tastes edible and
what do I like to put it into my body
stains that are edible there you go
there is your official lies Danya for
all of you that are trying to maintain
healthy diets this year if you enjoyed
this video give it a thumbs up let me
know what other kind of cooking videos
that you might like to see in the future
and click this one right here and
subscribe to this YouTube channel
because we got really intelligent
content like this happening pretty
regularly and consistently regularly I
don't know oh my god cottage cheese you
don't even taste it damn it and feeling
really good about this